morning John good morning Hank it's
Friday questions Friday the day that we
answer real questions from real
nerdfighters let's get right to it how
many times have you read The Fault in
Our Stars have a high I don't know I
mean how many times I've read the
finished book yeah the one that's out in
hardcover yeah that one zero why would I
read lots of other books that other
people wrote that I could read that I
don't remember when do you read it twice
I read it once before it came out once
after it came out thanks for reading it
twice what's your favorite book series
at the moment my favorite book series is
always gonna be Harry Potter
I like divergent a welliton which one of
you would win an arm wrestling match
it's gonna make for bad video
laughing so yes uh-huh I won with my
whip did you Hank ever cry to one of
John's books yes I looked at it and I
cried too I also have cried to one of
John's books if you got to give each
other catchphrases what would they be
imagine complexly shares would actually
be fart fart fart how do you like your
eggs I like the brand of a biscuit can
you please show us some family photos
from when you two were younger fun
antics you should ask because we're in
the room that has the photo I don't know
if I want people to see this that's
pretty cute you're giving me a little
bear hug which one of you is hotter
we'll have to have a poll like I'm not
objectively able to perfect that's just
what I've always needed is a poll to
determine whether I'm hotter than my
brother she asks dance montage shopping
senses
I'll have pizza on Thanksgiving no we
have normal Thanksgiving maybe someday
we'll have turkey Pete favorite kind of
pie pumpkin pumpkin also a problem
because there's only one pumpkin pie is
there this Thanksgiving almost like The
Hunger Games in that one of us is gonna
be hungry and the other of us is gonna
be dead if John was a turkey and he was
the last Turkey on earth would you eat
him for Thanksgiving no I mean are there
other foods available could I have a ham
but also if John were a turkey I
probably wouldn't think very highly
I'm just amused by the idea that anyone
no matter who the turkey was would eat
the last turkey on earth there's only
one turkey left and it is Thanksgiving
it's like we found the last ivory-billed
woodpecker and just be like well who's
gonna get to eat them how do you do
drawings of one another yeah I did mine
it's Farkle pen paper what do you think
um yeah I've always wanted to Hank with
fish earrings
I drew Hank as well um I drew him as a
beaver playing the guitar what's the
worst kind of candy I think the worst
kind of candy is probably a candy none
of us has ever heard of because the
person who created it was like well that
clearly is puh one time I went to a
contemporary art performance at which
the artist who was Chinese handed out
hard candy that tasted like crabs and
was a very bad candy this person just
says bad jokes I tell you a physics joke
but you'd probably find it boring but
you know jokes about Dorian Gray they
never get old
his dftba.com doing anything for Black
Friday so are we heck yes there is $3
shipping on all orders no matter how
much you order you will get it for just
$3 shipping even international what have
you have friends and family we're
looking for Christmas presents for you
maybe there's something you want to let
them know about how do you make a really
good project for awesome video thank you
do a good project for awesome video is
not just like sitting in front of a
camera and talking about why a charity
is important to you but actually showing
it at work and also consider the fact
that you're basically pitching a charity
you have to let people know why this is
important why it's a big deal why it's
important to you personally yeah the
best project for awesome videos are also
videos that the charities themselves can
then use and their own outreach to their
donors
when that happens and we hope that it
happens a lot this year have y'all
always been really close no I mean we've
always liked each other though thank you
for watching best wishes
dftba John I'll see you on Tuesday bye